UGH!..
Family friendly f..(jibberish)
sorry I didn't think
Family friendly Felix!
Welcome!
Welcome, everyone! Clap it up!
(applause)
Clap it up, everybody!
Family friendly Felix here!
And I'm just!- I don't know how to make it stop..
(applause stops)
Um..
I'm not making any money.
As you may not know, there's an adpocalypse going on right now.
There's no ads on Youtube.
No ads. Okay?
They're all gone, they all pulled out.
Because apparently, there was... uh ads on a racist video.
So everyone was like, "UH I'm out."
Aright.
There's, there's what? 9 billion videos on Youtube?
AH, that one that said racist on it!
Nope!
I'm out!
1 out of 9 billion
Fuck you!
If you see an ad on this video...
You praise that shit, like the fucking sun.
Okay?
Praise that shit, boi
I want you to suck that.... FAMILY FRIENDLY FELIX HERE
by the way...
I want you to
gently...make sweet ....*blanks*
Family friendly ...
uhm
*laughs nervously*
need to learn how to use this fuckin sound board
Alright so lets have a look here and see what
did my last video make
on ads.
a hundred dollars?!
*gun shot*
the irony here is that i made more on youtube red revenue
So! check out my new show...uh..
oh wait, fuck
uh...they fucked that up too
the news outlet that broke
this story about
uh....the racist video
was none other...the enemy of YouTube
*laughs*
The wall street journal.. I'm not kidding
they're back at it again
remember when I... I
did the whole *fuck you finger*
try again mother fuckers
(try again mother fuckers)
you weren't supposed to actually do it
WHAT THE HELL MAN
GODDAMNIT!
FUCK
FUCKING YOUTUBE RED. I'm fucked.
oka ...im just..dont panic
I'm sure no one else is panicking
"I declare war on the Wall Street Journal'
OKAY maybe people are panicking
just a little bit.....just a LITTLE bit
thats fine... desperate times call... comes desperate measurements
and FAMILY FRIENDLY FELIX got a plan
boi
I got a..
I've got a... I've got a plan
how did we do it back in the day?
ok?
HOW did they do it back in the good ol' day of youtube 7 years ago?
*shows a video from 10 years ago*
THIS is the content we need to go back to
ok?
this is..
10 TIMES BETTER
"charlie bit me"
its genius...its brilliant
its...almost a billion views.
*knocking* my sound board's not..
*JACK SPEDICY'S INTRO* OHHHHH...
MINECRAFT. The game i have been avoiding since i started youtube
MINECRAFT
the BEST game in the goddamn world
THATS what people want.
MINECRAFT
more MINECRAFT. we need more MINECRAFT
FINALLY i am going to play minecraft
i haven't played it..in i dont know how many years
i refuse to play it but here..... *look intensifies*
£18?
i cant afford that ._.
LUCKILY im swedish...and i have a secret..secret...uh...secret plan
for this .-.
doesn't wait...doesn't windows come with..
OH it does
it does okay...
cool ._.
HEY ITS CHEAPER
oh fuck that...free trial
" Add your microsoft.."
I DONT HAVE A MICROSOFT ACCOUNT
its THIS hard to be family friendly
ok...aw fuck, ok
toms....toms guide. YES
this is what i wanted
YESSS
I QUIT. I QUIT
im now living in the minecraft world
HELLO SHEEP you'll be my new friend
they do roleplaying when they play minecraft so they do like funny voices
"hellooo i am sheep. HA! le memes"
there wa-
sheep what did you build over there?
"i dont know"
See im really good at this..
im REALLY good at this
AWH hell AWH...
GODDAMNIT SHEEP
you gone get it
you gone get it....you gone get it boy
i beat the shit out of you
fuck piece of shit
fuck piece of...goddamnit
NO REGRATS
*dab to the sad music*
*switches to minecraft music*
people play this game everyday?
alright then
*breaking grass blocks*
i guess if im gonna live in the new minecraft world i need to build a house
this is where i live now
ok
alright...goddamnit
its gonna be...pretty fucking cool guys
i mean...pretty cool...pretty SWELL (that save tho)
and also just know that there is not
a platform and services related to virtual communities in which members interact primarily on the internet
okay?
this is NOT that
you know im actually enjoying the game which makes me think maybe i have autism after all?
im building a wall!
im building a wall..
if trumps not gonna do it
Family friendly felix is gonna do it
alright we're gonna build a wall
you know that concept with family friendliness?
people aren't just gonna go back on it okay?
the reason why people love youtube
is because...
it's free and it's open
and you can say whatever you want
it's not like television where everything is behind executive producers
and people telling "no you cant say that!"
because then we'll do this
and "no you cant say that" sadjhasdjl
it seems like youtube..
is forced to turning into television at this point
thats gonna be bad for everyone
you want youtube to continue being a free platform
i would want youtube to be...a free platform
i understand that advertises need to feel like
they're spending money and it's not showing up on racist videos
i understand that 100%
like..thats a terrible thing, if i was spending money
and i saw my ads showing up on racist videos i would be like *wtf*
but the whole thing is just so..massivly overblown
it's so typical
for these things to just get way bigger then they should be, in the media
talking first hand here. It's...its like what?
5 videos they discovered...i...based on the whole platform?
there's like what? 9 billion videos on youtube
and..and people are worried about five
I agree its.. like its still a problem
but is it...ugh
should everyone on the platform be
affected by 5 racist dudes?
EGH
that just doesn't really make sense to me..at least
im sure youtube will b-bounce back and i hope..
I PRAY
for everyone
thats a smaller channel
that they can hang in there for now
uhhh.... because
i used to be at a point on youtube
where i was so dependent on my next paycheck
i didnt have anything set up. i had just started off
and i-i needed that monthly paycheck so...
this month, most likely a lot of creators are not gonna get paid
so its weird to combat that
just a lil bit
uh...i wanted to do another shout out competition. ive done a couple in the past.
so if you're interested in getting a shoutout
uhhh...they been...they've been successful
and pretty good so.
check out the link in the description
there's specific rules and i really appreciate that you go by them
uh, make sure that you are quick and concise
with.. following them
if theres too much text im not going to have time to read it
and im just going to have to skip it. no smugness intended
but im...but im fine
like...im not going to stop making videos just because im not making money
i...i meant it when i said
i-i do it because i love it...and
THAT BENG SAID
IF YOU SEE AN AD
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
♫ Praise, Praise, Praise the sun ♫
also uhm
going to twitch now...pft *laughs*
i decided this before. okay?
before anything, so don't read-ed it the wrong way
but i-i wanted to start doing streams on twitch
so uh...we are gonna do a weekly stream
over at twitch, its starts... SUNDAY
this sunday i mean...
so uhm over at youtube.com/netglow
netglow is the brand that i wanted to create
thaaahht i wanted revelmode to be
but no one liked the name
check the...i mean netglow
it means cooler on the internet then in person
i think thats a pretty fucking perfect name
so its going to be...
a streaming show once a week
potentially more... i really want it to be something
AHHHHH sort of like we did with revel mode or like we did with cringemas cause that was so much fun
uh so definitely be sure to check that out
come show your support
uh...PRAISE..ya know
and all that stuff-
*dat face